let's read this first story we have this
one from timcast.com and i know some
people are saying whoa whoa whoa this
headline is misleading or let's let let
me read it for you biden tells the 82nd
airborne they're going to ukraine
contradicting previous promise
president joe biden told troops from the
second airborne division stationed in
how do you pronounce that uh raziao
poland probably probably absolutely
wrong we need where's jack when you need
him or luke uh that they would be going
to ukraine during his first state of the
union address the beginning of march
biden promised that he would not be
putting american boots on the ground
quote let me be clear our forces are not
engaged and will not engage in the
conflict with the russian forces in
ukraine however biden's words in poland
imply he has changed his mind quote
you're going to see when you're there
you're going to see women
young people standing in the middle in
front of a damn tank saying i'm not
leaving
so we have this from the daily mail
white house forced to correct by uh
biden after uh forced to correct biden
after hinted u.s troops would be sent
into ukraine in slip in speech to
paratroopers in poland
following biden's comments to the 82nd
airborne division in poland the white
house clarified saying the president has
been clear we are not sending us troops
to ukraine and there is no change in
that position all right i just got to
say there's a few scenarios here one
joe biden is a fumbling bumbling fool
and just was misspeaking saying you'll
see it when you're there maybe he meant
something else i honestly don't know
what could it mean to to tell a troop
they'll be seeing people standing in
front of a tank saying you know they're
not moving or whatever
could joe biden have accidentally said
this
could he have accidentally leaked
advanced plans
is the white house lying
like is it a false like a false signal
we're going to be in the center is joe
biden nuts
all of i think all of it's on the table
it's all plausible all for all four of
your uh scenarios are plausible with
this with this guy
he just sounds so tired like all the
time like i people make a lot of
mistakes when they're tired and they're
you know their sleep patterns are drawn
out he's in poland right now so he's
traveling i could absolutely see
something like this being a slip up that
he's just not ready for public speaking
when he's that tired or that out of it
yeah like he's already got a
hypothetical setup in his mind so he's
like when this hypothetical comes that
is a hypothetical this will be the
situation yeah but the word when i mean
rumsfeld said this about the iraq war in
2002 before we were in iraq afghanistan
only he was like when we go into iraq
and it was like a signal like what do
you mean when what do you mean when
heck's not on this isn't part of the
game right now yeah well it yeah well it
is part of the game for them
yeah for sure i would be mind blown if
the united states was not preparing to
send troops into ukraine in some way
absolutely or they don't already have
them there in some way i would be
shocked if joe biden wasn't taking mad
uppers of some sort like this is the
kind of situation where you pay
privateers this is where privateers came
from you put people into ukraine you pay
them but they don't wear american
outfits they're just being paid by the
american government you know you know
you mentioned that uh biden seems tired
all the time and watching these past
several videos
he is like when he was at the g7 when he
was talking about the new world order
and stuff he's just uh talking like this
you know i was talking to this guy in a
secure military he said
you know going to be a new world order
and i'm like
you know what man
they must have this dude on so many
pills to keep him moving
because tr for someone his age to be
traveling overseas to europe
changing sleep schedule working this
much
i don't know how he does it because i
gotta be honest i'm tired yeah you know
and i stay in this house most of the
time just working it it's tough for me
to you know watching it
um i think we live in an age of double
crosses and triple crosses it's very
hard for me to tell whether or not he's
being puppeted or if he he's just in on
it and he's that sinister and i think
it's very hard to tell with a lot of
these global figures in positions like
his
i have a hard time believing that his is
on purpose or that he's doing it on
purpose i actually believe that drug i
remember sticks hex and hammer had a
video when he got elected where he's
like i hope the cia he's like i don't
want him to be president but if he is
give him the good drugs
cia i hope they give him the good stuff
to keep him awake so that people don't
think uh our president's falling asleep
he's completely right you know make him
make make him work give him something so
all right let's
let's say this
outside of whatever the whatever biden
is is supposed to be saying and whatever
he meant
i don't know what do you think man do
you think they're going to send troops
you think nato will get involved you
think the u.s troops are going to get
involved in ukraine go up against russia
it's hard to say i i think
ultimately
um
there is a four player jump ball
geopolitically you got the free people
um of of many nations around the world
you have your globalists you got russia
and china
and you know i think glenn beck laid
this out well i've written it before my
sub stack
china and russia want a a nationalist
dictatorship and the globalists want an
international dictatorship and i think
ukraine is is the the proxy ground for
the war between the globalists and and
and china and russia in many regards and
you know we're in the fog of war it's
hard to say what they'll do i would i
would lean towards
um they probably will you know intervene
in the ukraine in some way coming up
shortly when i think about like who's
who would win from a war between the
united states and russia china i mean or
be like the oligarchs like klaus schwab
but like when i think of kolomoisky and
how he created that tv station to put um
zielinski on a tv show and then he made
the political party to put zolinski into
power who's he who's he connected with i
think the people that win ultimately in
this are the
um central bank
financial cartels
um and when you when you push
you know nations
on a global stage
to this level of of pressure and
desperation and and you know
it's all it's ultimately going to affect
the currency yeah it's also it's
ultimately going to potentially crash
the currency which would give them the
opportunity to usher in a new global
digital currency which which takes
authoritarianism to an entirely new
height and i think that they i don't
think that they've been shy about saying
that that's their ambition i think that
we
as individual citizens who don't have
that type of sinister
mindset find it hard to believe that
they would sacrifice people in the
ukraine or anywhere else in order to
achieve that goal
now we've got food shortages coming
yeah by fall because of fertilizer
because of exports in
ukraine i think ukraine and hungary are
pulling back on on wheat exports so
europe they're going to be going hungry
quite a bit devices are going to
skyrocket
was like a human created massive
starvation to hold a more is that
um i wouldn't put it past an
authoritarian regime to murder hundreds
of thousands of people to get a an
agenda across it's it's been happening
plenty of times in the past i i view it
more like uh
or millions of billions i wouldn't even
put it past them to kill half the planet
to get an agenda across you got to watch
out for psychopathy
well i mean here's here's a point you
know first of all when you bring stuff
like that up the media just dismisses
you and calls you crazy i'm not saying
they're doing it i'm saying i wouldn't
put it past them the media will dismiss
you and call you crazy which is crazy
serial killers exist
many there have been many serial killers
who were very very smart and it's
terrifying how how calculated they were
now imagine one of them just decides to
get in office yeah how hard is it i mean
you know heaven help us if a serial
someone a psychotic individual serial
killer mindset it's a high ranking
position in the military also drugs make
people crazy i think hitler was on so
many drugs and yeah it was a big part of
what pushed him over the edge they were
doing meth
kept going you know i see some of these
politicians who have been elected let's
say like an ilhan omar
and i've said in the beginning of this
campaign i don't know how much she's in
on it i don't know how much he's
initiated into these sort of global
level plans um but a lot of them are
useful drones for much more predatory
and and sophisticated uh predators i
mean you know players at the top level
and
yes
sociopathic psychopathic uh character
traits are all on the board i don't
think that anybody should dismiss them
in fact i think it's a it's a concerted
effort for the mainstream media to
dismiss these things out of hand because
they're in on it
oh yeah the mainstream media the fight
the five-headed hydra the new world
order is very clear to me you got big
tech
you got the three industrial complexes
military media and medicine and you got
the central bank cartels and and they do
their best to make it seem like they're
not uh you know in on it together but
when you really take a step back and
look at these things from a broader
scope they they all interplay and they
work together to you know to to quell
what stories they need to and promote
others i'm going to pull this up every
time someone mentions the new world
order just so that i can say here's what
we're talking about this is the council
on foreign relations news guard
certified 100 out of 100 and they say
what is the liberal world order they say
world leaders created a series of
international organizations and
agreements to promote global cooperation
on issues including security trade
health and monetary policy the united
states has championed the system known
as the liberal world order for the past
75 years during this time the world has
enjoyed unprecedented unprecedented
peace and prosperity i i will dispute
that yeah right but uh but but this is
the idea this is the council on foreign
relations whether anybody you know they
say what is the new security council if
someone wants to come out and say the
new world order is a crackpot conspiracy
whatever it is you're talking about fine
sure when we were talking about big tack
and and the monetary fund look at this
don't they i think they actually mention
the international monetary fund in here
do they let me let me make sure they're
doing it right we're all definitely
people yep
do they mention the world not even
they're so brazen about it there we go
look at this look at this evaluate the
success of the world bank and the
international monetary fund and
promoting trade development and economic
stability so we're talking about the
banking industry big tech and all that
stuff
just if you've got a problem with us
believing that uh take it up with the
council on foreign relations own website
which says it's real that's the only
thing i have to say is okay then if you
think that's a conspiracy theory
that was crazy counsel on foreign
relations people putting those
conspiracy theories up they tricked us
oh man how dare they and when they mean
peace and prosperity they mean here not
where we're using it
yeah overseas for the first time we bomb
where we drop a bomb every eight seconds
it's it's peaceful here just not all the
other places where our influence is i
mean in the west it's peaceful in the
west for the most part i don't know i'm
pretty sure if you look at the southern
border with the cartels and
some of the most dangerous parts of
mexico are right on the southern border
of the united states so
yeah i'm not i'm not about to agree with
them like it's been unprecedented
precedented peace and prosperity you're
saying the whole premise is false it's a
non-starter i mean yeah yeah they might
be have something to it because there
was like how many hundreds of millions
were killed in the night in the not 19
or the 1900s like yeah
one and two was the most grotesque thing
the humans have ever done to themselves
really it was disgusting and we haven't
done that since we built this so that's
the upside and before in the 1800s it
was probably as gruesome not as gruesome
because machine guns changed a lot but
pretty damn gruesome in the 1800s too
like really really bad so this maybe i
mean i do think for the time that this
had a purpose but that the purpose is
passed i don't think that we need to go
to an autocratic global corporate
governance but i think that the liberal
economic order is over well i think it's
just real quick i think it's funny that
they're like what is the world trade
organization what is the world health
organization what is international law
but the new world order is a conspiracy
theory yeah like what
organizations exist i think what we're
looking at right here is
the fallout from um
a psychopathic man
named adolf hitler committing a a very
evil atrocity on a certain group of
people and and wanted to expand an
empire and have the german war machine
go and take over the world and then you
had a bunch of opportunists
whether out of fear or out of ambition
um
see the opportunity to use him as a
scapegoat to say the only way we could
stop this from happening is if we
consolidate power into international
governing bodies um and and and what's
interesting about the way they want to
do this is similar to how they similar
to what china has done if you notice
with china and how they've reinitiated
the re-education camps they call them
re-education camps because they know and
i'm not not to say that the chinese the
ccp hasn't killed uyghurs or cultural
minorities in these camps what i'm
saying is that they've moved this sort
of overton window of what it means to be
um tyrannical and evil in a societal
framework so they'll say we're not
killing them like like they did it
like they did the jews we're just
putting them in re-education camps and
that sort of quells the visceral feeling
we have towards what happened to the
jews and i think the the the u.n and
these globalist international bodies are
doing a similar thing when they talk
about peace but then they're they're not
talking about the peace of of soul or
the peace of spirit uh they're talking
about physical conflict but the whole
scam is to make people very chaotic and
unpeaceful in their minds and bodies and
spirits yeah you can you can chain two
people up and they call it peaceful
because they can't fight but they're not
going to be happy that's not a good
piece for those people it's still a
degradation of humanity and dignity
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you